we have this chart basically showing you
each of the seats that Labour is
defending so remember that these seats
the most pretty much all gray at the
moment these are the seats labor of
defending and at the start of the night
all of these were red okay so these are
labor seats and it would take up to a
four percent swing for the Conservatives
or indeed other parties to win these
seats so reading East Croydon central
would take up to six percent
stoke-on-trent central we're all west up
to eight percent but look at this up to
ten percent swing it would take to win
Blythe Valley we are starting the first
game for the Tories is right at the end
of the spectrum of what a lot of people
expected and this is Labour's red wall
you heard that talk about the red wall
that label was defending it wanted to
withhold the Tories particularly in
these seats here well right from the
start
they have lost one on a pretty enormous
swing a ten percent swing and what's the
story behind that we'll come back and
have a look at this we're gonna actually
kind of drill into a few of those seats
so let's drill into boy Valley and
indeed some of the other seats come over
here and see some of the stories kind of
behind them so this is the change in the
share of the voting you see the Tories
up by five points four percent but look
at labour down by 15% and brexit party
up by 8.3 and then if we have a look at
Houghton and Sutherland South kind of
you know similar story actually labour
down 19% there in terms of the share of
the vote the Tories up by 3.2 he breaks
it up by 15 point 5 percent obviously
from from us kind of start of 0
effectively and here you have newcastle
upon tyne central as well it's a similar
story labor just cratering votes across
these constituencies and what's Houghton
assembled and South employed finally
have in common it is the fact that they
are strong brexit supporting areas you
know it is the brexit vote which might
well decide this election we talked
about it being the brexit election and
how right that might well turn out to be
have a look at this the map of the UK
with all the different constituencies
let's take these and plot them against
their brexit vote so that's the most
remain over there moving through here to
kind of middle-of-the-road to the most
leave seats and there we have Bligh
Valley so that's there you can see they
voted just around kind of 60%
to leave the EU and what we are
potentially going to see if the exit
poll is right is around this area which
is Labour's red wall we're about to see
a lot of these seats potentially turning
blue if the exit poll is to be believed
so we're going to be plotting all of
these results against all of this now in
the past it might have taken some days
for people to work out this kind of
analysis showing you about how the map
is changing what kind of divisions we're
seeing in this country we're going to
try and do a few tonight over the course
of the next few hours so stay tuned as
we get more of these numbers through